alors on va faire un tour de table de
qui comme dirait d'accord ou la ti comme
mireille n'a jamais voulu se marier
tâche avait voulu te marier mairie n'ont
pas trouvé un way attend l'arrêt j'ai
trouvé mais pas pour me marier alors
dont je n'éprouve pas de besoin de marie
on peut aimer quelqu'un sens miles away
un grand amour je me suis rien à l'année
dernière
tu as trouvé l'amour tel contrat de
castaldi toi non mais c'est vrai mari
bon j'ai trouvé l'amour la mort et mes
vives et voici le goût de 15 fois par
les aidons à balleroy moi aussi je peux
trouver un voile à alata fait toutes les
pièces de la maison avant dans un cache
cache et trouve la personne alors qu'ils
nous si jeune âge arrive au mirail
vous ne sentirez pas mieux que mireille
c'est vrai que voilà c'est là une petite
angoisse m'en avait parlé déjà sonné par
me bonne mémoire oui elle est bonne mais
moi actuellement sur le plateau
mp oui tout à fait et vous étiez à cette
place là bas mais j'ai une mémoire alors
si vous voyez le mange mon coeur et je
n'ai pas encore je n'ai pas de promoteur
parce que j'attende que je me promenais
quel que soit le pays bon je suis
français et fier de l'être
roux mais parfois je gêne interprète des
chansons dans différentes langues et
mais c'est quand je travaille ses 24
heures sur 24
j'ai besoin de daf de pouvoir
transmettre mon émotion personnelle et
mes sentiments au public qui est devant
qui a payé cher mais celui qui a payé
trop cher leurs billets a aussi chers
comme le regard en dit l'heureux le
regard est le reflet de l'âme
c'est important de l'ama encore un jour
livre être libre de pouvoir s'exprimer
et ne pas avoir un prompteur mais c'est
un goût à la raison c'est pas la chose
personnelle pendant je sais mérimée
charest bien vos amis mais je suis
encore je suis d'accord parce que le
prompteur tepa de dante épave dans we
jean michel meyer à moi non plus j'ai
jamais voulu marier mais ma meuf mans
plusieurs alors hawks étaient bien
contents ils voulaient mais beaucoup
donc et pas de déclin quand je pourrai
prendre un journaliste qui a besoin d'un
promoteur parce que les informera c'est
tellement important ça y est ça je peux
comprendre vraiment confiance mais
cherchez pas
mais c'est vrai nom mais poids
franchement un chanteur avec un
prompteur c'est vrai que c'est relou
bostich d'accord avec toi qui comme
mireille n'a jamais n'a quasiment jamais
changé de coupe de cheveux
mouah ah bah non quoi vous à quoi bon je
les perds un peu mais je note très beau
tout n'avance pas question que ça
mireille méritas jamais choisi de coûts
annoncé l'eso contrat avec bérengère
chantiers bu2 porte unifiée et changer
de coiffure j'ai fait toutes les
coiffures
ouais mais souvent ne peut pas ne pas
aimer ma coiffeuse j'adore mais je me
sens bien dans ma coiffure l'avenir est
alors la mode est un éternel
recommencement donc tu sais tu y
parvenir dans dédé en présence de la
mode de la ve dernièrement il y avait
des défis coiffa bien sûr ça revient
dans un café quand je sais je sais j'en
ai vu plomberie
alors qui comme mireille faisait déjà de
la télé en 1979
laurent baffie exactement la ferme et m
parce qu'on a retrouvé une archive
incroyable c'est en février 1979 dans
l'émission numéro 1 sur tf1
et dans cet extrait on voit mireille
mathieu et laurent baffie sur le même
plateau
et ouais c'est vrai on regarde leur ont
regardé dernier mot
d'amour
m
tout alla pénétrable
tout allait rentrer
m
mais bon que le dieu
[Applaudissements]
jardiner mais c'était visible chance je
peux dire que c'est une chanson
brésilienne parce que s'appelle à voler
dans les airs brésilienne des mots
d'amour écrit par claude lemesle the way
qui comme mireille mathieu et hyper
maniaque
il paraît que quand tu étais petit
mairie tu vivais à 16 dans un cinq
pièces et comme tt 1 à 5 dans l'enceinte
ps pendant l'été action tu voulais tout
faire pour que la maison soit nickel et
qu'on puisse manger par terre alors je
vais expliquer nous habitions parce que
je suis l'aîné de 14 enfants pour il ya
des personnes qui ne savent pas oui et
avant bien sûr qu'on soit 14 ans vivait
dans des baraquements en fibrociment
évidemment nous étions il y avait la spa
chambre des parents et notre chambre
fille
on dormait dans on a envie qu on avait
en lits dont condanmé 5 dans le lit aux
pieds la tête puis une championne et les
garçons et on était bien sûr les trois
étaient chauffés par par le poil on
n'avait pas de douche en se doucher à
l'école en scène maman mettez sur le
poêle dans une masse une bassine d'eau
pour pouvoir se laver
mais il y avait tellement d'amour que
peu importe j'ai la chance de grâce à
mon métier je dois de dire que la douche
a été une chose très importante pour moi
est d'avoir deux doigts d'être dans les
plus beaux hôtels près des suites les
plus belles la première chose que je
vais voir se sont lâchés la salle de
bain soit ou la douche voilà bien sûr
est bonne c'est ce qu'ils disent est un
leader
je disais quand on me demandait quel est
pour vous le signe de réussite
moi j'ai dit c'est les les toilettes à
l'intérieur parce que à une période de
ma vie j'ai passé plus de temps avec les
toilettes à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
il toilettes sur le palier les toilettes
sur le voilà alors le luxe pour moi
c'est faire caca chez moi d'accord
préféré que sur le plateau voilà qui
comme meriva tu as une passion à
laquelle on ne s'attend pas du tout bas
c'est vrai au mirail vous êtes fan de
formule 1 c'est pas du tout voilà l
adorent ça on a d'ailleurs une photo
étonnante vous êtes avec olivier panis
ancien pilote de f1 pennesi jean reno
est nécessaire y avait eu lieu il y
avait tort oui j'ai entendu un acteur
ouais ouais pourtant elle n'a pas le
permis de conduire parce que je ne sais
pas quand vous confondez je crois la
droite et la gauche
oui weatherill un gars les six jeux
suivants tu votes c'est la merde
[Rires]
monsieur le pen merci pour tout ce que
vous faites alors mireille n'apparaitra
coiffure il ya un instant s'arrêtera
jamais changé moi je change tous les
deux jours et cette coupe est tellement
mythique que de nombreuses personnalités
du paf ont essayé de copier mais ça va
pas vraiment à tout le monde
regardez regardez regardez mesdames et
messieurs bonjour cinq ans dit le temps
est toujours gris 7 3 10 9 8 et 7 663
mes chers compatriotes c'est avec
beaucoup de tristesse et d'émotion que
je m'adresse à vous ce soir
zèle près qu'il bouteilles d'eau kits
servette et médecine ball alors on y va
mireille mathieu 12 après cette petite
vidéo voilà mirail mais on ne change
rien tu es magnifique comme ça mireille
vraiment je te le dis